vladimir putin to be called ruler of
russia under new proposal a pro kremlin
party is calling for vladimir putin to
be referred to as the russia
russia's ruler rather than a russia
president in order to move away from job
description derived from a foreign
language the national
liberal democratic party
proposed replacing the term president
with the pavitel which means ruler
because the term president has not yet
taken root completely in russia ran uh
state-run uh outlet ria novosti reported
dell dpr said that the using of the term
president has always been embarrassed
embarrassed us the party argued in its
proposal that the term was first used at
the end of 18th century in the u.s and
much later it spread throughout the
world since this is newsweek what's this
all about with ruler there it is how do
you feel about this all right i i feel
about this the way i feel about a lot of
the coverage of putin which is that you
know
the guy is a thug the guy is a murderer
he has you know russia is not a real
democracy
but at the same time i feel like there's
a kind of unhealthy obsession and a need
to make him
much bigger than he is
in the media and in american politics
and i think that that is connected to
trump i mean this is a new thing in
american politics i think our greatest
adversary is china and i don't
understand why we haven't been trying to
make alliances with russia which was
more democratic before we took this
adversarial approach
um you know in in in in an alliance
against china which is actually our
greatest adversary i think russia's like
yeah the war in ukraine is horrible it's
it's devastating but at the same time
that doesn't make russia more than it is
which is essentially a petro state and
we've screwed over our own working class
and our americans and americans
pocketbooks and their ability to achieve
our middle class life um by taking aside
too strongly in this conflict so that's
how i see it you know i'm not this is
not praise for putin he's a thug and a
murderer
the war in ukraine was absolutely
unjustifiable but at the same time you
know we have a lot of culpability there
we have not done the most that we could
to make sure that things did not end up
here and i think that we've actually
screwed ourselves over when it comes to
fighting china which is a much bigger
threat
[Music]
well i you
check check check everything you said i
totally agree with
um you hit the nail on the head i think
the famous quote is uh russia is a gas
station masquerading as a country yeah
and you called it a petrol state i i'll
never forget the conversation we had
with the great director oliver stone
here and i was like who does putin want
to be you know stalin lennon he goes no
no no you got to go further back
and he said he wants to be peter the
great
and now this just kind of confirms all
that where he wants to be called the
ruler
the president is no longer so in my mind
he's more of an eve on the terrible than
peter the great
but um this is this is
and then the last point is i i we need
to refocus
our agenda away from the russian
nonsense and focus more on china we talk
about
that's our biggest adversary but for
50 years it was russia and we've slowly
seen china yeah
you know become the number one
potentially number two country in the
world right now behind the u.s i think
they're set to take us over gdp wise by
what 2030 and that's where our focus
needs to shift so i'm not unders i'm not
completely sure why we're so focused on
russia
it's uh we can maybe can't just shake it
from our dna from the last 50 years i
don't know listen to to make it into
russian politics for as long as this
guy's made it he's not a dummy he's
doing this for a reason
from the outside you may sit there and
say what a terrible timing to do this
because you're allowing the world to say
look how egotistical you are to be
called a ruler there's a motive behind
it the world's going to find out in
about two to four weeks on the real
reason why they want to make this
transition
uh who knows what the reasoning is but
it doesn't show me that it's progressive
it shows me that it's kind of
using this crisis as a way to go
backwards to give even more control to
him
than going in the direction where the
people are really
in charge of that country it's just
saying no you know you're right they're
not in charge of country but look at the
end of the day the last two years we've
definitely not worked on strengthening
this relationship at all
so we did not get uh
you know closer to our enemy to calm
them down
we've actually screwed this thing up and
we're spending too much time high fiving
and uh what do you call it fist pumping
guys from saudi arabia hey what's up
doug you know hey yeah i know you guys
killed that one journal it's all good
don't worry about how you doing it's a
very weird uh foreign policy approach
that we're taking it's quite
embarrassing if you think about it to
the world on how they're viewing it so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]